question is boys was the tour of success
oh massive success I mean a better
question Robert is would we do it again
yeah I think a lot of people you know in
Europe and Southeast Asia would want a
tour and uh they were very vocal about
how annoyed they were they didn't get it
yeah and they were like I don't care
about the tool I don't see anything
about it the amount of Europe tour wins
yeah southeast Asia we're definitely
considering stuff like that because the
first one went so well yeah I think yeah
I mean I think uh I don't know if this
can be a spoiler but we we recorded some
of the shows and we're gonna we're gonna
put some of them on YouTube uh but I
think even after that one thing I liked
about the tour was that we got to learn
about each place we went to and there's
so many more places and so many more
shows I want to do in different places
to like learn about what goes on in that
place the culture of that place and I
think if we were to do another tour we
probably would not do exactly the same
format or exactly the same show but we
would probably take aspects of this show
and try to do it you know in a more
worldwide uh worldwide more places
worldwide I think one thing as well that
again like you know was a great thing to
come out of doing this tour is the fact
that we've learned so much about how to
put on a performance in a stage setting
yeah which I think is really valuable
and uh you know it's you know I
personally learned a lot of skills doing
shows on stage that you know I can
utilize on trash test recordings or like
you know just regular videos and stuff
like that right and it's like this it's
just like a cool and also you know like
it's just a cool thing to be like yeah I
went around America doing shows and [ __ ]
like that on stage it was pretty dope
yeah like it's just like a cool story
and experience and you know like from
the amount of stories we've already told
just from this episode it's like
invaluable yeah I I will say if we do a
show again we'll probably do less shows
yeah
23 was too much 23 was too much I got
back and like I haven't like streamed
haven't even tweeted because I was just
like I need a period in my life where I
just don't have an audience watching I
was like I just I just don't need an
audience right now and I was just like
chilling out just doing nothing
um and
that's because 23 shows is way too much
also I think I was like the only one
that actually got ill on the tour as
well I got sick twice oh okay I got sick
once right before we started and I was
like oh no please
towards the end yeah it's like I think I
had to like perform like the last few
shows with like a pretty bad fever which
was difficult but hopefully I I got told
that no one really noticed it no no you
hit it very well yeah but that's because
like as I was literally in like I was
literally in Sage Mode the entire day I
didn't see any of these boys I was just
like by myself on the bus conserving
energy for this two-hour show because I
was like dying in bed it was in monk
mode yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
I was like Gathering energy I was like
what you can do with this gun you can do
this
um so yeah 23 shows is a lot uh probably
to do less shows but I I would
definitely want to do more shows yeah
hell yeah for sure yeah I enjoyed it it
was just too long yeah yeah but the last
Slide the past like last week we week
and a half two weeks I was kind of like
all right everybody ready to go home now
yeah think about Japan okay yeah I
missed Japan yeah I think though I think
I'm just glad that like you know I
because again this was our first tour
right so I think we all three of us
weren't really too sure if we were gonna
bro I did not know what exactly I
actually experience it like nothing you
know just we'd heard from other people
about like how tours went but it's like
you know not every tour is the same kind
of thing right so you know I was just
hoping I'm like please
I just want to come out of this tour
liking what I went through yeah luckily
I did so I think it was like awesome
it's like you know I think a lot of
YouTubers
um and streamers whatever they often get
in the Trap of like never leaving their
house and you're just making stuff in
your home and I feel like you were
saying a lot of really cool life
experiences that could enhance maybe
even your content or how you view the
world oh for sure and allow you to learn
and expand your horizons you know I
think I think traveling is one of the
best ways to just kind of open your
mindset a bit and learn from other
cultures yeah and so I think it's uh if
you get the opportunity to do it you
should always do it I genuinely learn a
lot about America industry yeah I did I
feel like I know a lot more intricacies
of the US now yeah and how States view
each other and how they interact and how
States well they're proud about what
they what they love talking about yeah
um and I think I speak for all of us
when I say this um that you know we're
really grateful to everyone who took
like a gamble on us essentially because
we didn't we'd never taught before there
was absolutely no reason that this was
going to be good there was nothing to
tell value that it was going to be a
good show yeah you know and a lot of
people spent a lot of money spent a lot
of time they were driving you know four
or five hours to come to these shows and
was buying hotels and buying a lot of
tickets and you know just at the uh just
at the opportunity to see us and maybe
hopefully have a good show and uh that
night it was gonna be good yeah um I
hope that we'd think that uh you know
everyone who came that we made you proud
and that you enjoyed the shows yeah we
really really appreciate the support
yeah I think it uh you know it just kept
blowing me away every time everyone was
like man I've traveled five hours to get
here tonight just for this and it's like
yeah damn dude yeah I was crazy thank
you I would not travel five hours
would not travel five hours for me yeah
because at the end of the day you know
all we wanted to do was put a good show
for you guys yeah and that was the only
worry that we had and uh you know we did
our best and we you know and we saw how
uh how well it was received from you
guys and it's that that's [ __ ]
awesome yeah there's definitely some
shows I'm like I'm just too tired but
then you get to the Q a you see how
excited everyone was yeah I gotta put on
the [ __ ] good job yeah no I don't let
these people down got to do it for these
beautiful boys already I know like every
time I saw that crowd I was like I just
don't want to disappoint I just don't
want to disappoint yeah and no matter
how early I was or whatever I just like
I figured out that if you know when I
see people and I see like like the
dedication and just like how you guys
were just so excited I was just
something awoke and I was just like I
just really really want to make this a
good job yeah I hope we are delivered
yeah I hope everyone who came to the
show had a great time and it was worth
running in time yeah and uh maybe
another tour soon who knows yeah so
we'll figure it out though if we do it
won't be America again yeah right well
not right away Europeans the southeast
Asians like yeah
yeah I mean I would love to do the show
again and find out more about Europe
yeah Southeast 100 yeah